eight years ago today the virus took all
the world's men
is rare that's why we've established the
repopulation lottery
survivors
[Music]
The Cult of Wellness has spread like a
cancer
and Lang has no intention of slowing it
down
[Music]
allowing her to be mayor Peter Valley is
one thing
allowing her to be prime minister of the
whole country
a lot another
day is the start of a new era
on three two
now our dreams are manifest
the government is a puppet show
Wellness is pulling the streets
she's doing what we all saw her do only
a hundred times worse
it's been four years of having my nut
harvested
I'm not leaving until land pays for what
she did
if anyone has a problem with that
they have to go through me
we strike at midnight that's very late
[Music]
thank you